briefly for sessions on T for local and
regional policy makers you've heard
basically the foundations and you've
heard tube for business now we're moving
into the policy-making context at the
local level I've been coordinating this
volume together with her a player Gandhi
Maidan from IIT Bombay and it was
launched in September last year
simultaneously in Ghent Belgium Cape
Town South Africa quality of ghazal and
New Delhi before I go into this I
briefly like to talk about our role in
team so our being the herald Center for
Environmental Research where I'm based
and our role besides the coordination of
this local volume was the overall cheap
scientific coordination so that involved
a lot of management of the process but
also trying to ensure consistency
between the different groups and because
as you might might might have heard all
these groups were coordinated by
different people had their different
core teams and so that they wouldn't
come up with four totally different
volumes that are not consistent with
each other our role was to overlook this
process and it it was quite a team at
our Institute we also had many many
interns at least two dozens of them
might say without whom we've never been
able to manage the whole thing and yeah
besides that was the was the process of
the tea / local very briefly they
hammered Center for Environmental
Research is a government-funded research
center in Germany focusing on the
environment maybe we have a very very
strong focus on Natural Sciences so out
of 35 departments there are four social
science department all the rest is some
variation of geology hydrology biology
ecology modeling etc and then we have
four social science departments from
wool and urban sociology and economics
environmental politics and environmental
law and planning so if any of you be
interested in joining us either as an
intern or guest scientists we'd be most
happy to have you read also plenty of
red brick buildings at least in Leipzig
not quite as nice as here but definitely
an interesting environment if you are
interested in environmental sciences our
main air fields of work our water
resources land use change in
biodiversity chemicals in the
environment and health and environment
okay now back to teeb you've seen this
slide and or variation thereof and I
just highlighted in red the two things
that I hope to contribute to with these
next four lectures so cheap especially
to you too parlons way of leading it end
of moving it sees itself also that
you've initiative as a catalyst of
change within society and I'd like to
reflect a little bit upon you know what
are where are these changes needed and
and what can we do in order to achieve
the last one here which is awareness
raising and mainstreaming and
mainstreaming meaning taking it outside
of the group of the already converted to
other areas and fields of
decision-making we're really change is
needed and but where priorities are
different or with the problems we see as
yet invisible okay so these are the
topics to be addressed in the 4d two
lectures are you familiar with this d0
d1 d2 stuff yeah okay
we try to avoid it but it's very deeply
ingrained so first of all the lecture of
today on how to integrate ecosystem
services in decision-making I'd like to
talk about a couple of frameworks and
look at processes I'd also like to
provide more on the side and overview of
the tube for local policy and especially
go into the our so called six step
approach then the next lecture on next
week tuesday is actually the merger of
two lectures which will be on natural
resource management and on poverty
aspects i think there for many
situations very related so i think that
that can be pulled together because
parvin has asked me to leave the last
session as a only question and answer
session because he felt that was in your
interest so if you don't disagree that's
how I'd go about it and then the third
lecture would be on ecosystem services
in urban and spatial planning okay if at
any times they are questions don't
hesitate so now back to your question
after this lecture I hope you will have
understood at least some of the
challenges of integrating a new concept
in practical decision making processes
an overview of frameworks that include
ecosystem services an understanding of
the local decision-making contexts
although that it's probably much more
than we can achieve but at least some
initial steps towards this and an idea
on how to go about assessing the
importance of ecosystem services for
local development if time permits also
the last aspect on differences of
private common in public good if not
we'll start the next lecture with that
one ok so the G to report what can you
expect from it well
okay first of all what is the idea the
idea is that this volume is supposed to
be useful all over the globe in very
different context so quite a challenge
of sorts to fit that into some 200 pages
and therefore it's quite clear that it's
not a manual or toolbox in the sense do
this do that do the other because that
would be impossible so what our guiding
principles were was we wanted to provide
a source of inspiration some telling
examples from around the world where
we'd hoped people would read it and say
okay well that's an interesting idea I
won't be able to do the very same thing
here but I might try out this or that
aspect we wanted to provide an overview
of approaches and instruments tools in
an easily accessible fashion and an aid
to orientation on the potential on the
requirements but also on the caveats of
applying assessment and valuation
instruments it is structured in poor
parts first one is a basic introduction
to ecosystem services and the value of
nature for local developments of trying
to sell this idea to an audience that is
in a situation of having to respond to
very divergent multiple needs and not
per se interested or all aware of these
issues the second part is on tools so on
frameworks on the one hand this is
mainly do we did a stakeholder process
we did workshops in in many different
countries on all continents discussing
this with with our potential end-users
and especially in the beginning there
was a high level of confusion that
they'd be asking well
we've just talked about nature
conservation biodiversity is ecosystem
services something different or is this
the same thing in a different in a
different disguise so the level of
confusion that this can create is is
high and therefore we felt okay let's
let's try and set out different
framework so that people have have
possibilities of linking these new
topics to other things they've heard or
have been working with and then chapter
3 is essentially a summary of of what is
in here on the valuation but hopefully
in a language that is accessible and of
course not with the with the scientific
and academic background but on a very
practical level then the main part of
the report consists of different fields
policy fields of application and some
possible types of instruments with local
level examples outlining the
opportunities and the potentials and as
I said some examples of how this has
been applied and finally the last part
is some conclusion of sorts but also
this trying to point out issues that we
consider important in in applying this
so issues of participation for example
issues of integrating different types of
knowledge ha's issues of Rights property
rights and how these are affected and it
has a session of some seventeen to
nineteen whatever I'd say a fake use so
questions and our tries to answer these
in a in a globally applicable fashion in
these lectures here we will mainly be
covering chapter two today then chapter
four and six in the last lecture chapter
5 in in the next lecture and chapter ten
between all of them and popping up again
and again
on on the how to making it work okay I
think yeah the other topics have
basically have either been covered
chapter 3 has been covered much more
deeply through through the d0 lectures
and you will be looking into some of the
instruments josh has covered the PS and
certification and labeling so if you're
interested in a more polished maker
context of what can I do at the local
level to foster certification or to
enable my local producers to participate
in certification you you may want to
look at chapter 9 and maybe the same for
PS you've heard it from a business
perspective here's a slightly different
perspective or highly complementary
perspective on these same issues the
main rationale was let's try and get
this information spread and let's try
and put this into an accessible format
for people who are not experts so it's
very often the origin was some
scientific paper we found somewhere on
an interesting valuation study the first
criteria we had was to only include
examples where they had actually been
policy uptake and and and implementation
this proved very challenging so we kind
of loosened that rule slightly and
included other to us interesting or
telling stories in the collection as
well okay now in the next three slides
I'm just going to run through quickly in
as examples of how we've been trying to
communicate in the different occasions
to this type of audience local level
policymakers this can be people in NGO
is this can be people in public sector
etc so what's the situation nature
provides bundles of different benefits
and this natural capital is neglected
both as a condition for local well-being
so some examples of
in national parks you can have a lot of
people depending directly on on these
resources and policy-makers being quite
unaware of the situation also the
potential of restoring ecosystems to
provide bundles of benefits like the
example from Tanzania where were
pastoralists are now again with sources
of further fuel and better water quality
especially in the dry season through
recovering traditional woodlands but
also as an asset for local development
if we look for example at the situation
in Brazil with 89 planned hydroelectric
dams if the the sediment there's an
estimate that sedimentation load in
forested watersheds is about half of
what it is in others so that reduces the
lifespan of these planned investments by
half if we don't take care of the
surrounding natural environment and
figures like that one-third of the world
cities already depend on protected areas
directly to receive their drinking water
another slide telling basically the same
story we'll look into some of these
cases in what detail power and has
looked at the has discussed with you the
water pump example and this is the main
focus we've been trying to take
presenting the whole thing as an
opportunity and a possibility to say
help save municipal costs so the example
of Quito is drinking water that is now
much cheaper where sherds through to
national parks compared the Kampala
example that the naki rules want that
power and has also presented to you
effectively treating sewage protection
against natural hazards boost the local
economy
no I'm not sure if you heard the shark
example of valuation of sharks and the
Maldives showing that when used for
tourism the value was about 10 times
that of killing it and selling it on the
fish market and it can help tackle
poverty okay this picture and the
example don't go together any longer
we'll look at this bangladesh example in
the next lecture now i'd like to talk
about briefly about frameworks can
someone tell me what what a framework is
and how it is different from a theory or
a method any suggestions
yep
Oh
it's just boundaries problem but you
have freedom to different tools yeah
yeah thank you very much that's pretty
comprehensive definition so the idea of
a framework is really to focus our
attention to certain aspects and then
within this framework we can see what
are the theories that are most
applicable to our our problem of
interest and then apply different
methods to find this out so here a
collection of four frameworks that touch
upon or have to do with ecosystem
services and I just like to briefly
highlight certain aspects in each of
them you're all familiar with the
millennium ecosystem assessment and this
is basically where the concept of
ecosystem services has come to some kind
of popular knowledge there's an ongoing
debate in ecology and for much longer
but this is where where this concept has
come to a broader setting and now it
looks rather trivial to say okay we have
certain ecosystem services and they
directly provide input to human
well-being but I once listen to a
presentation by ignore God who was
involved in this formulation of this
framework and he was telling us about
how many workshops that took them to
finally agree between natural scientists
biologists ecologists on the one hand
and then social scientists on the other
to bring these different points of view
and end points of interest together if
you consider that
usually ecology biology looks into
functions and processes and yeah social
science might be interested in the fact
is nature happening on it so know is
it's constructed by by the respective
Society you you have quite a bridge a
gap to bridge what maybe is is the most
prominent add on to this from teeb is
this although it's not from teeb as most
things are not originally from tea but
just pull together by the Teva nishat of
is this differentiating between or from
biophysical structures or processes that
form the the under that are the
underlying fabric of functions to
services to benefits and then finally to
economic value and this has proven Lee
you'll be useful heuristic and the point
I want to make with this is you I think
you've been focusing a lot on the
economic value aspect of it I think
often in in communication and if we look
at the examples it it's very very useful
to focus on the service and benefit part
before we look into the value part so
that there's clarity on what are we
talking about and where does this come
from and it's also important to keep in
mind that yeah this is these are five
distinct things and these little arrows
up there they imply a lot of assumptions
and there's a lot of well there's a lot
of research still to be done to
understand the relationship between them
but also it's we can't really jump from
this last box directly to the first ones
let's say
we can't do a contingent valuation study
on some microbes or worms in the soil
because people will not understand this
unless they understand all these links
in between and the other point I'd like
to stress and I'll come back to that
over and over again is this is this
benefit benefit is always to someone so
benefit is something that is that
certain people in society have and if we
have a total economic value that usually
doesn't tell us one bit about who has
these benefits how are they distributed
and and who might and these might also
be this this economic value is a balance
of positives and negatives possibly so
we might have people losing out with
whatever option so besides focusing on
the economic value it's essential
especially if we go into the real world
situations where these trade-offs occur
that we look at benefits and to whom did
I see a hand trying to be raised there
or okay okay so much for the millennium
ecosystem assessment you all know the
total economic value framework I just
like to briefly look at some of the
advantages and disadvantages well one of
the main advantages and why I defended
against a lot of critiques from the
especially from the politics department
it is comprehensive all types of values
can be looked at in this framework it's
also a good frame way to translate all
these different types of values into
economic terms and
make them comparable however if we come
to the practical side of it it's usually
very costly if not impossible to get
good is estimates of total economic
value especially of all ecosystem
service is concerned so usually we are
more or less obliged to make some
selection of sorts but again due to its
comprehensiveness it's useful that when
we then communicate our results we make
clear okay this is only part of what the
total value is because we can only look
at part or we are only interested in
part of it now what all the other
dimensions come on top of this another
disadvantage of operating with total
economic values is that in a practical
political process once the total number
is out it's very difficult to modify now
come to an example to illustrate this in
a minute it is also not sensitive to who
benefits as I have just pointed out with
the previous slide and it does not
integrate systemic issues so everything
you've heard on thresholds or tipping
points or aspects of these this nature
cannot be addressed with total economic
value framework per se it needs a
different take it needs complementary
complementary aspects and it's quite
abstract so if you're well trained in
looking at values and in identifying
different types of values it's useful
heuristic but if you're maybe a yeah a
practical decision maker on the local
level and not very well used to it it's
not it's not helpful in the sense of a
checklist what do I need to look out for
it for you know order to fulfill such a
purpose it needs translation into more
concrete dimensions than just talking
about option values or non-use
that's just a little bit more about that
mean so if the valuation stuff is
difficult for local populations that
said understand terms of governance how
do you get around that and is it a
properties of just a communication point
and we circulate policymakers import
interested
we better communicating with its numbers
me or is it a sequencing point in the
sense that you want to make certain
decisions sort of before you know you
may do the evaluation me present the
numbers I think there's a there's a
criticism that and it's a reflected I
think slightly near sort of point about
once a total numbers out of modify i
think is in person criticism of
evaluation stuff that you know when you
attach a dollar amount to experience
also very salient and maybe slots other
considerations and a policy or local
political context so I mean you know can
you just talk a little bit more a bit
later yeah i will be talking more about
this in the in the entire four sessions
but I'll give it a try in a very natural
way I think the the main the main point
is and this is an ongoing eternal
discussion also in also within the teeb
group and it's I think no coincidence
that both Patrick can bring and myself
who are on the policy makers volumes
much more critical of the valuation
approach than push bum or or George what
but still and as I said on my team I've
we've had people who are very very very
critical of the whole thing I think
there is a big value inn in having these
numbers and there's even a big value in
having non-monetary numbers to start out
with so making clear so so many
livelihoods jobs or protein intake or
whatever depends on this is a very
powerful tool of communication and and
so our money values but I think it's
really essential that whoever operates
with them understands where they come
from what they say and what they don't
say because they easily get out of hand
and I've issue I've experienced that
myself on a TV interview that they did
for me 25 minutes on on TV two hours of
asking me questions
and I've said these things at least 35
times in these two hours and they cut
them out every single time and it just
ended up being a show with such-and-such
price tags such and such price tag and
that's what gets communicated that's
what survives so this is it is
challenging to transport it with with
but if you are an actor in a political
decision-making context and most
decisions on nature and on ecosystem
services are political decisions then
it's extremely helpful if you're aware
of what you are operating with what the
context of this is as I said total
economic value make sure you at least
communicate my number looks only at the
provisioning services or my number looks
only at to regulating services out of a
set of at least six at plus they are the
cultural and social services so so even
just this framing it and packaging it
can help and can take us quite a ways
because certainly especially in cultures
like here in the US or in the UK where
you where you operate in the political
arena with with cost-benefit analysis
and dollar values on on many many many
issues and I think there's no point in
not valuing it because then to the
implicit values simply zero but that is
more or less than the challenge and the
balance and that's what I'm trying to
get at does that helpful now so this
example from Durban where yeah typical
situation where nature is not at the
forefront of people's mind 3 million
population thirty to forty percent
unemployment at the same time it does
contain 47 biomes in South Africa 2000
and agendas plant AXA and has a
tremendous coastline which is of course
also of
from a biodiversity point of view so I
think it was the mayor who who pushed
for evaluation exercise and showed with
this quite impressive number of 400
million u.s. dollars annually and this
is also not total because tourism was
excluded for reasons that I'm not not
aware of but some practical reasons and
this this created quite a momentum and
awareness among among the city
administration and some of the major
players to to actually look out okay
where are our open spaces and what what
is happening to them because most of the
remaining open spaces are in private or
communal hands and our zone for further
development but so this DISA teves some
some awareness and some protection was
was possible but on the other hand okay
principal pressures on the other hand
then a proposal came up to expand on the
trade port and showing yeah operating
with numbers in quite a different order
of magnitude and then argue with you
know we don't we don't even want all
your area we just want a tiny bit of it
and this is so much more this is so much
more attractive economically and in that
moment this whole argumentation with
economic numbers that was started off by
putting this this price on their kind of
backfired because it was very hard to
bring back other types of arguments okay
briefly on ecological approaches I'm not
an expert on this I'm just going to try
and make one point they are different
different concepts and since many of you
have been working in environmental NGOs
you'll be much more familiar than I am
with the practical working of these
so hot sports or or read lists or
critical biodiversity areas the point is
they can be very useful and they can be
included into a setup of valuation by by
making by let's start the other way
around let's this is an example of a
salmon habitat so restoring of a river
system to allow the Salmons to come back
and this is an area in the in the at the
mouth of the river the estuary that is
quite decisive for the ability of the
salmans to move into the river so if
they they did evaluation of and if you
look at only the impact of these two
hectares on site that was quite quite a
low number and and the value wasn't high
and could certainly not compete at all
with alternative uses however when
considering that these two Hector's are
quite essential for the Salman to be
able to move up the river and that
actually if if this were not
rehabilitated the whole project wouldn't
be working out so by taking into account
the off side effects the the value went
up considerably and even if the the
opportunity costs for in this case an
industrial area where higher than this
and I can't quite remember how it was i
think they weren't but even then you you
can definitely argue here with the
irreplaceable ax t of this particular
area for this particular use whereas the
industrial area might be moved move down
slightly and might have some trade-offs
to face but have has other options so it
it is very useful to to screen these
these different ecological concepts and
perspectives to see what what is the
importance and how do we
include this how do we involve this in
our in our evaluation or assessment
exercise okay sustainable livelihoods
approach I've heard several people
who've been working in namibia mexico
bolivia in countryside settings you
might have heard of this this is mainly
been developed by the UK overseas
development community i don't
particularly like this framework but
this graphic because it's slightly
confusing with too many errors which
mainly highlight the complexity but the
point I want to make is that here they
explicitly look at the capital assets
and their importance for for livelihoods
which is straightforward but besides the
financial physical and human capital
that most approaches look at they also
include social and natural capital
directly so it is a way of focusing our
attention on what is the role of natural
capital for livelihoods of certain
groups so where does in this setting
over here where does this dot end is it
close to the inside so not important or
is it quite far out and it's this
framework unlike the others does focus
on the importance for certain groups in
society and their livelihood
implications maybe I'll leave it at that
for now we'll come back to these
concepts when we talk about poverty ok
so these you have also been discussing I
guess in the previous lectures so
challenges to integrating nature's
values time differences when things
occur spatial differences where things
are clear what I want to come back to
later on today is the multiple levels
involved we've talked about the
invisibility
you find some conceptual orientation on
on all these aspects in the D 1 chapter
2 and D 2 chapter 1 point again that I'd
like to stress here is that ecosystem
services are usually an additional layer
of information I modern steering
committee for initiative in Canada
Alberta who look into wetlands and try
to apply an ecosystem service approach
with the with the objective of showing
okay what is the additional value of of
ecosystem services and many of these
discussions there's there's plenty of
local decision makers on the the
steering committee as well many of these
discussions are yeah but we are already
doing that aren't we and and how is this
different from what we're doing now and
do you expect us to do I don't know how
much on top of all this so you will
always have some kind of of taking into
account but that might be partial it
might not cover all services so it's
important to get some kind of an
understanding of where where things are
so that we then can can add on to them
so we can't come with a with a concept
and a new new tool on top of everything
because that's just going to be
additional effort and serve to confuse
people okay my favorite tip case pollen
has also talked about this but very
briefly so you'll hear a little bit more
on it now establishment of an marine
protected area and the Philippines this
is the area this is the reef in the
zulus II there was increasing awareness
in the 80s that these reefs were at risk
that they are important habitat for
multitude of species provide the
surrounding sea with fish lava lava
and of course an appealing destination
to drivers so protection was enacted at
the national level by declaring a marine
protected area by a presidential decree
no take policy with the logic of keeping
this area out of fishing would increase
fish fish yields in the surroundings but
it ended in the typical conservation
development divide so implementation and
especially enforcement was difficult and
nothing much happened in the first ten
years why because fishes were not
convinced that the knotek policy would
increase their catch and also not in a
position to wait and see what would
happen by reducing their catch so this
workshop organized by an NGO brought
this position to light and provided a
forum for the fishes to present their
situation and make clear why and why
they were not in a position to
collaborate what they then did so yeah
the need for for empirical evidence that
this would actually help and would
actually improve the situation which is
of course difficult to provide
especially in fisheries but in almost
any situation of recovery where recovery
of course takes time what could however
be measured and provided and and made
visible immediately was the value of an
of the MPA to the divers and and op
tourism operators so willingness to pay
conserve a was conducted among them and
with this management could be improved
in the sense that user fee system was
was established based on these results
that they were able to involve the
locals and the fishes in the management
and patrolling etc
and set up a sharing scheme for
distributing these this this income and
thus allow Fisher's to to compensate for
for income forgotten in fisheries this
then made possible over the next couple
of years to actually assess changes and
showed that fish mass biomass increased
that livelihood increased perceived
catch increased etc so lessons from here
well several challenges that are typical
for restoring or improving or conserving
ecosystems implementation is a long term
process usually a challenging bal it's
challenging to balance the different
interests between different stakeholders
because almost always we will have
winners and losers and change especially
recovery takes time and this information
especially on changes is often hard to
obtain and hard to convey so again we
have this this issue of invisibility
also of improvement helpful elements
well dedication of local actors to
involve stakeholders and thereby thereby
break up this impasse the creation of a
common information base there's plenty
of examples showing that this is an
important and step that then allows
building a lot of other things on top of
it transition management so the
possibility to immediately capture value
and compensate and in a more general
sense lesson from the cases are that
often overtime solutions are found there
is a learning curve and hopefully by
disseminating these examples and
spreading them others can not take 11
years to organize their workshop and
achieve these types of results earlier
now whoops stop here in in the d2 we
present the so-called six step approach
it's in the book version that will
appear next year next year it's my it's
much more present much more visible here
it's basically presented in chapter two
and then picked up again in chapter 10
the new version will have examples
following this in all the chapters this
is a basically heuristic of aspects that
we found were important in different
cases that we looked at and that we
think should be taken into account so if
you like also some way of frameworks of
procedure of its own what are these
points well first of all specify and
agree the policy issue ideally with
stakeholders if you're not able to
involve them directly at least try to
think who the stakeholders are and what
their interests in positions might be
identify which ecosystem services are
most relevant so make a decision on
where to focus and how to to embed your
study define the information needs and
select appropriate methods this is a
step that yeah many there are plenty of
procedures of this type but this is a
step that many don't include explicitly
but it's it's begin to pick up the issue
from earlier if we are to embed
evaluation study or even if we don't go
all the way to monitor our evaluation
it's important that we we are conscious
of what are we what is the purpose what
are we trying to show with this and
based on this what is the level of
detail what is the the expanse what what
are the appropriate methods to be used
and and also you usually we have the
situation that as a local policy maker I
don't make my own assessment I come
this to someone so it's in our opinion
and experience important to be aware of
what I what I handle when would I ask
for and not just say okay value this for
me please and then not be able to
understand what the underlying
assumptions are and what is actually
telling me four steps straight forward
assess and fifth step then identify and
appraise different policy options
especially with regard to their
distributional impact now I'll go
through these different steps in the
next slides maybe you can put yourself
into a position of imagining your class
project for for this course and try to
answer the questions with regard to your
exercise so what what would that mean in
your specific cases yeah so step one
specify and agree what's what's the
point this ensures that all important
aspects are being considered and avoids
misunderstandings during these dishes
making and especially implementation and
these so-called surprises and
unintentional effects that then pop up
if we don't look at the situation in a
comprehensive manner beforehand so
initial stakeholder analysis or if if
time and budget allows participatory
appraisal methods are appropriate tools
to facilitate this part of the process
and you find in brackets here the
chapters where you can find some
additional information on this in the in
the D to book
the third point i'll come back to in the
lecture on the urban planning so they're
armed they are managing frameworks or
tools set such as the eco budget that
facilitates putting this concern for
ecosystem service on to a continuous
basis so to set up sis the information
management systems where we can follow
this monitor this over time which of
course makes it then much easier to
identify issues and and agree on on
problems step 2 so in your settings
which ecosystem services are central
first of all central to the setting so
either the local setting the economy but
also the culture of the society or the
business or whatever you're looking at
who depends most on them which services
are actually at risk where where are
changes occurring where I'd drivers
pressures that that are putting things
at risk and how do policies affect these
I think I've made most of these points
before importance to get clarity on what
exactly you want to know and for what
purpose and here and this is something
that runs through the detail we have
plenty of examples that don't go all the
way to monetary valuation but many of
them yeah even if we can qualitatively
describe the importance of certain
services this can help to create the
awareness that we're looking for
biophysical quantification or then
monetary valuation I guess in your
projects you'll all be doing going all
the way through to the monetary level is
that the intention yeah okay
step 4 anna says so here again just some
tools and and frameworks that might help
in this practical assessment finally
looking at policy options that I think
especially at the local level there's
usually not much point in just doing an
assessment at the national level it
might make a lot of sense to get some
inventory of sorts but usually you are
facing a particular situation you are
interested in certain change to happen
or not happen so useful then also to
think directly how can this feed into
possible options of affecting this so
this goes all the way from informing the
debate which is of course the most basic
can be an input in cost-benefit analysis
can also be part of a multi-criteria
analysis are there again we can bring
different types of argumentation and of
aspects into the picture that go beyond
the monetary or the or the economic
arguments and it kind of course also
serve as an input in policy choice or
design so determine a tax level or help
to determine the planning setup where
certain activities are allowed or not
allowed step 6 distributional impacts
will we'll come back to this in more
detail next week but again looking
closely at changes in availability and
distribution of ecosystem services
affect people and they depend to a
different degree so someone poor
depending heavily on this will be
affected by the same change in quite a
different way than someone in a better
off position there are different tools
and maybe this last point special
coincidence or overlap can give good
indications of where the hotspots of
problems might occur so very briefly
this story again because
we can actually fit it into the six
steps this awareness on which equals
system servers are at risk is of course
second step protection enacted is a step
5 of sorts even if it does didn't
compare different options or look into
that design carefully then the workshop
with actually getting a common
understanding and step one defining
information needs improving the
management so steps 5 including the
distributional aspect step 6 and then
after all this the actual assessment so
what's the point I'm trying to make here
this idea of these six steps is not that
they need to be followed from one
through six they they can be used
flexibly they can be should be adapted
to the specific situation but i do
believe at least consciously looking
into each of them before you decide not
to do it is is is very helpful okay
we've basically covered and discussed
this now what I wanted to do when I'm
afraid time will not allow because if i
read this clock correctly when
practically at the end well maybe you
can take this home with you and think
about it what I'd like you to do and
maybe you can do it for your cases so
that it's not an additional homework but
part of what you're doing anyhow is to
think who are the actors and who are
also potential stakeholders so who else
is affected by whatever issue or
potentially affected by whatever issue
i'm looking at period of mining company
company a housing development or
whatever and what are their interests in
these ecosystem services the second
exercise is then how does the national
or any other type of higher level could
be a regional could also be the
international level intervene are there
any mechanisms
are there any influences the Philippines
example showed an action of policy at
the national level without consulting
the regional local what other mechanism
there are plenty of other interactions
there so what other aspects what other
policies what other circumstances are
affecting your situation